l'image du jour c'est bien sûr le coup
d'envoi de la COP 27 qui débute
aujourd'hui en Egypte avec près de 100
chefs d'État et de gouvernement réunis
dont le président français Emmanuel
Macron et il sera notamment question de
la facture des dégâts climatiques qui
touchent beaucoup les pays du Sud et qui
réclament ces pays des dédommagements
financiers par contre on a un petit peu
dans un contrôle en tous les cas c'est
très joli moi personnellement tout ce
qui est campagne et tout non il y a rien
autour de toi il y a que de l'herbe des
cailloux moi j'aime pas trop l'urgence
climatique est bien là elle n'est pas
pour demain et la meilleure punchline
de solidarité climatique soit un pacte
de suicide collectif
au cœur des discussions un fond de
soutien financé par les pays développés
Emmanuel Macron appelle les États-Unis
et la Chine à payer leurs parts à deux
reprises l'État français a été condamné
pour ses manquements en matière de lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique parmi
les points noirs les énergies
renouvelables elles représentent 19,1%
de la consommation énergétique française
l'objectif fixé à ce stade était 23%.
fini le temps ou en 2018 récemment élu
Emmanuel Macron était désigné champion
de la terre par le Programme des Nations
Unies pour l'Environnement lui aussi
était présent et bien présent l'homme
avec un grand H
je suis battu pendant tout le monde
croisait les jambes sauf lui le seul
l'unique
Walker Texas Macron et sa grosse paire
de dossiers à gérer
alors on discute climat les enfants on
discute pas climat en 2009 un fond
d'adaptation avec déjà été voté il
devait financer 100 milliards d'euros
tous les ans au pays en voie de
développement mais les pays riches n'ont
pas tenu leur engagement en 2020
seulement 83 milliards sur les 100 ont
été récoltés
à Paris dans 25 ans ça peut être vrai ou
pas alors dans les 20 ans qui viennent
la température planétaire va
vraisemblablement prendre 0,4 degrés
c'est à dire qu'on va dépasser les 1,5
degrés qui aujourd'hui servent
d'objectifs à la COP 19 et pas un degré
de plus à Toulouse les écoles de la
ville devront passer l'hiver un peu plus
au frais pour réduire les coûts du
chauffage pas surprenant pour les
parents 19 degrés effectivement ça me
choque pas dans la mesure où c'est ce
que nous on applique à la maison et
effectivement c'est viable alors c'est
sûr on se balade pas en t-shirt en hiver
à la maison
RTO vient de publier les chiffres de
consommation d'électricité en France
pour le mois d'octobre tout doux Doom -
% alors vous allez me dire bah oui mais
c'est normal Valérie Maurice
comment je fais participer tous mes
camarades dans les chroniques Valérie
Maurice a expliqué que ils étaient très
beaux mais RT recalcule en gommant
justement les effets météo si on enlève
les effets météo et bien malgré tout la
consommation d'électricité a baissé en
octobre en référé météo de près de 6%
tout va très bien Madame la marquise
tout va très bien tout va très bien et 8
milliards d'habitants sur terre un cap
qui sera passé le 15 novembre prochain
selon les Nations unies la population
mondiale qui a bondit en moins d'un
siècle en 1950 la terre comptait en
effet 2 milliards et demi d'individus
l'onutables sur 8 milliards et demi en
2030 et 9 milliards sept en 2050 mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais tout seul
Sébastien je suis arrivé tout seul parce
que j'ai décidé de pas aller en Alsace
en fait après la violation qui a été une
situation un peu on va dire compliqué à
gérer pour moi c'est plus facile à gérer
entre autres cochon que de femmes dans
une maison quoi
[Musique]
une croissance démographique qui soulève
la problématique des ressources
rappellent des ONG comme WWF il faudrait
ainsi
1,75 TER soit près de deux planètes pour
subvenir aux besoins de la population de
façon durable dites moi on va faire un
débat sur le
réchauffement climatique et le
dérèglement climatique on peut pas dire
vous contribuez à l'émission de gaz à
effet de serre vous avez toujours pas le
permis 80 pays donc
un paradoxe sur pattes c'est lui Eddy
Mitchell
non non
conducteur jamais parce que si vous êtes
des Halles conducteur si vous l'attrapez
vous lui faites coucou qui c'est on va
être dans la mouise regardez ces images
tourner ce matin sur le périphérique
parisien des militants du mouvement
écologiste dernière rénovation bloquée
la circulation
avant d'être délogé par les forces de
l'ordre sous collectif exige du
gouvernement d'agir dans les plus brefs
délais pour freiner la catastrophe
climatique qui condamne son inaction
qu'il juge criminels
[Musique]
je crois que c'est compliqué je crois
que le trajet est long
[Musique]
[Rires]